new in theaters this weekend the Meg
Slenderman and dog days what will you
see this is your weekend ticket jason
statham plus a giant shark what could be
better the Meg follows a group of
scientists on a submersible research
laboratory as they are attacked by a
75-foot prehistoric shark called a
Megalodon
the mag must be stopped before
continuing his rampage on innocent
swimmers think of it as jaws meets the
transporter
good luck Jason we're all counting on
you chew on this you this movie is for
you if you love sci-fi horror films the
ocean freaks you out and you kinda like
it or you just need a two-hour break
from the summer heat but you don't
actually want to get in the water
Slender Man ocean horror not your thing
but you're still looking to get freaked
out this weekend Slender Man is for you
originating from an internet-based urban
legend the Slender Man movie follows a
group of teenagers as they set out to
investigate the Slender suit-wearing
faceless creature man after one of their
friends goes missing haunting and
possession ensues
this movie is for you if you like urban
legend style horror movies you need a
good midsummer pre Halloween movie
season scare or you just want to see a
guy who really knows how to wear a suit
and finally if neither ocean horror or
urban legend horror strikes your fancy
check out Dog Days this family-friendly
dog centric comedy follows several
seemingly unrelated but related dogs and
their humans as their lives twist
together like dog leashes on a group dog
walk
it's basically Love Actually with more
dogs and less Christmas and it has a
star-studded cast Nina Dobrev Vanessa
Hudgens Adam pally Eva Longoria and Rob
Corddry just to name a few this movie's
real if you love dogs you think dogs are
cute you're dog person
dogs are your thing or you're a cat
person but still like a good story that
is your weekend ticket so what's your
pick dog movie or scary movie check back
next week for 22 miles of high-octane
martial arts action dude
[Music]